[Music]
for quite some time I've been getting
many requests from viewers and
subscribers and other fans that I do a
bookshelf tour and talk about some of
the books that I've got here up on the
stacks I recently put them into what's
more or less a coherent order it's
better in some parts than others so this
provides an excellent opportunity for me
to actually fulfill that request so here
is my bookshelf tour all right so we
start the tour with my Loeb library
editions these are the English on one
side and Greek and Latin on the other
side I make a lot of use out of these as
a matter of fact some of them are not in
particularly good shape that's Homearama
the very end and that's actually not a
Loeb edition that's the the Odyssey book
that I had from when I did readings of
that you know as a student in graduate
school and you see we start off with
some you know Homeric hymns and things
like that
and then we jump right into lots and
lots and lots of Aristotle you notice
that I've got quite a bit of that
another author who I'm pretty fond of
and I did buy some some works by is
Lucien of Sam soda
you also see it's some Plutarch in there
Epictetus Diogenes they are taste and
then the red volumes on the end are
actually Cicero and I've got quite a few
of those as well
the Cicero continues on and I think I do
actually have a few other volumes of
Cicero around here in the apartment
somewhere that I haven't put on the
shelf but those are the ones that I use
quite frequently I've also got a few
other things I've picked up here and
there some Ovid some Virgil some
augustine again the Loeb series and then
we've got some other cool things there's
a bunch of varied stuff some of the
Greek some of it in other languages
there's the Nibelungen lead in old high
german there's Grimm's fairy tales one
volume of it in in German and then
there's a lot of Rilke stuff there as
well I had a fan who bought me those
collected works that's those little
almost lilac colored volumes there that
you see six in a row and there's a lot
of other real connects to it as well and
then at the very end that blue volume is
again more you know old high german and
early writings a lot of cool stuff in
there some of it poetry some of it some
prose if i remember right it's been a
while since i've taken then follow him
down so now we get into the ancient
philosophy all of it in english
translation here on this shelf a few
studies and collected essays books about
ancient greek culture and then some
stuff on the pre-socratics then we get
some Plato stuff including two volumes
of the collected dialogue so that my
wife and I can both study them together
so I'm Victor Goldschmidt Studies which
I kind of like him on played on some
other commentators as well then we get
Aristotle I've got you know some of
these these classic sets of essays that
are quite nice and you know couple
copies of the rhetoric you know
different translations they do quite a
bit of work on that then we have you
know Lucretius in the epicurean
tradition we have a bit of stoic stuff
and we finish with this volume of the
you know the notion of happiness
starting with the ancients and going
into the
evils so then we have the actual
medieval stuff I've got that volume on
the philosophy of Judaism that includes
a lot of different selections 18 Jones
philosophy of the Middle Ages and in
French we got some Augustine's so booth
is lots and lots of stuff on and some
don't surprise given that I do a lot of
work and a handsome then we've got
Maimonides some stuff on Bonaventure and
we start getting into Thomas Aquinas
I've got quite a bit of Aquinas stuff as
you can see many of which are these
black friars editions which I like quite
a bit they have the Latin on one side
and a you know critical apparatus and
English translations on the other some
of the English translations not so good
some of them are very good
I've got translations of his
commentaries on the politics and the
nicob McCain ethics a few studies you
see echo and Jill song there then we
have done SCOTUS John of the Cross we
start moving into Renaissance authors an
early modern authors like Montaigne
Castelli on Nicolas of Cuza and then a
Galileo that's what that unmarked volume
is and then we have a lot of decart
stuff there I'm a big fan of Descartes
and I like reading him in the original
Latin in French and that little volume
there without us without a cover that's
Hobbes is Leviathan I've read it so many
times that I've pretty much worn it out
[Music]
so this shelf is thoroughly early
moderns a little bit more of Hobbs some
Pascal and then we get into Spinoza some
Montesquieu some John Locke actually
quite a lot of Locke there I used to
really focus on him quite a bit and then
Jonathan Edwards you know great American
philosopher very influenced by Locke
Bishop Berkeley and we get into
jean-jacques Rousseau yeah and then
we're moving into you know the middle
part of the modern period we have Adam
Smith and a lot of David Hume a little
bit of read some Voltaire Federalist
Papers Thomas Paine Edmund Burke Mary
Wollstonecraft Lichtenberg and then we
start getting into cons I've got quite a
lot of that because he is somebody who I
consider quite important you know so
I've got a couple different translations
of the critique of Pure Reason and then
a few other works by him as well
come to somebody who I enjoy reading but
these are the works that I actually
enjoy the most the moral philosophy the
third critique and the religion within
limits of reason alone which is
philosophy of religion but really mainly
ethics as well
then we I've got like a little bit of
Fichte and we jump right into Hegel I've
got a lot of Hegel's stuff the
phenomenology and a couple translations
the science of logic number of the
various lectures the the philosophy of
write some commentaries of various sorts
on on Hegel and then we've got
Schopenhauer and I think he's quite
important as well
I think many of you know that I'm a big
fan of Kierkegaard as well you notice a
lot of his works on my shelf and then
followed by some of the other
nineteenth-century stuff there's
Coleridge right there now we start
getting into the English authors you
know the utilitarians like John Stuart
Mill Cardinal Newman you even see some
Malthus in there and I've got some de
Tocqueville French author a very
important one as far as I'm concerned
and then we get to you know the left two
galleons like Feuerbach and and now we
get into Marx there's a little bit more
of Marx there and then you can tell that
my clasificado a system starts to break
down because there's so much twentieth
century and even 19th century stuff that
I've got and it doesn't all fit nicely
into a chronological perspective so now
I'm starting to place things sort of by
there you might say tradition and so
this is the Marxist influenced stuff
we've got you know or critical theory
we've got Rosen's like Lukesh Horkheimer
Adorno mark who's Habermas a few other
things here and there including a book
by my old mentor Garth Gill and rising
from the ruins and then we've got some
Jameson stuff and then finally at the
very end of that I've got a few things
that are there within the Marxist
perspective you know Lana and Stalin and
Communist Chinese stuff and I shoved it
in there so that's that's that shelf
another very important tradition is what
we can call the phenomenological and
hermeneutical tradition and I've got
quite a few of that you see who Cyril
kicking it off and then I've got quite a
bit of mock Schaller stuff and
hide-a-goose stuff you know those are
really the three key figures in early
phenomenology a lot of Heidegger stuff
in there quite frankly and then we've
got maurice merleau-ponty another great
thinker some Gabrielle Marcel and I
actually think I've got some other
Marcel around here that I haven't put on
the shelf I shoved Marianas guide
without being in there just to have it
in the phenomenological tradition even
though it's a little bit out of sequence
and then we've got a manual loving us
and a few of his works as well so we
continue that tradition with some books
by dietrich von Hildebrand a really
important Schaller student gadamer's
truth and Method and a bunch of stuff by
paul ricoeur big fan of his also a
number of things by Hana rent there's a
fun own thing in there and then a ton of
Derrida because I used to be really
really into Derrida so I've actually got
quite a few of his works including to
that that my mom bought for me while she
was in France knowing that I was you
know reading stuff in the original that
writing and difference and on Gromit
ology those are some some of my favorite
things because you know I remember her
buying them for me so a little bit out
of order but I wanted to place this in
here then we've got what we can call the
existentialism shelf with Unamuno and
ortega y gasset
bear jaya have chest a good bit of SART
stuff some Simone de Beauvoir I've got
you know some some Tillich and some
Simone vay and Boober in there as well
and then a good bit of Camus stuff and
then a number of different studies on
existentialism that you know some of
them are quite good some of them I just
have sort of as reference points
that I'll use later on
and then here's a shelf of stuff that I
think a lot of my viewers are not going
to be very well aware of but which is
quite important for me so I picked up a
number of Baird sone volumes and the big
fan of honoree barracks on actually and
then we have Maurice blown dal the guy
who I wrote my dissertation on very
important 20th century French Catholic
thinker influenced a lot of different
people including Peter Russo lo whose
intelligence you see there got some
Edith Stein I've got some Jacques
Maritain got got quite a bit of a tea
and Jill's so so these are all important
French thinkers of the 20th century then
we have a shelf that has a number of
things from the psychoanalytic tradition
and some things from some other modes of
psychotherapy you start out with a lot
of Freud including the collected works
then we have some some Freudians right
we have young and we have right and then
the other right
and then you notice that we we get into
Lacan and I've got a lot of Jacques
Lacan stuff because I make sure a big
fan of his might surprise some people
then we've got some stuff from the
cognitive revolution you can say
although we also have some you know beta
hime they're good to read as well and a
number of different interesting things
so the psychological literature spills
over into the next shelf and then we've
got a number of different things there's
a little bit more heterogeneous we've
got a lot of meetcha literature there
including in some cases multiple
translations a few bits high works some
baudrillard some leotard some Deleuze
and to losing qatari a lot of eigem been
somebody who's a contemporary author who
i like quite a bit so may dream pepper
Zach you know that's really a change of
pace for those of you who know their
works and at the end and rounding it up
ggx book on violence most of our gjx
stuff is actually
hacked up in one place or another a lot
of different things on this shelf we
start out with Bakhtin including a book
by val ocean off whose turns out is
Bakhtin then we have some structuralist
stuff the you know disel sir cordage
language TV genre which is really great
grass a little bit of other stuff on
structuralism some claude lévi-strauss
some roland Bart then we get into like
you know post-structuralist stuff with
Foucault I got a lot of Foucault stuff
that I've collected over the years he's
an author that I actually enjoyed quite
a bit and drawn quite a bit well on this
shelf I have a number of different
things all kind of smooshed together so
we've got American philosophy Emerson
through row purse Royce some James stuff
and then some some white head and and
white head is actually good transitional
figure given that he you know is kind of
an American philosophy but also kind of
in the you know brutish analytic
tradition as well given his
collaborations with Russell so we've got
some more plenty of Russell's some
Vidkun Stein popper although you know I
had to put some other things in there
that don't necessarily fit that well so
Nosek is up there and and Iris Murdoch
and and a few other things as well
[Music]
and speaking of stuff that doesn't all
fit in together this shelf is like that
you know you have to have some place
where you put the things that you can't
find places for on other shelves and so
we've got you know quite a bit of stuff
from contemporary continental you might
say some stuff focused specifically on
gender and philosophy even some stuff
within you know the broadly socialist
Marxist
radical tradition that just didn't fit
on that shelf you had to go down
somewhere else and towards the end we've
got things from the Christian philosophy
debates that I I had to shove somewhere
as well so here on this shelf we have
stuff that's really within the realm of
social and political philosophy we start
out with studies that focus specifically
on fascism and other similar movements
then we've got things that kind of fit
in with with the conservative ways of
thinking and then there's there's quite
a bit of variety there then then we
start getting into just stuff that fits
into social political theory broadly and
it's a quite a mix you know we've got
look back there and as a military
theorist got a captive mind you know and
at the very end you see that we've got
Lord Acton essays on freedom and power a
lot of other cool stuff and that's
that's gene Hamptons book on political
philosophy there at the end
then we have some stuff from the classic
sociological tradition Durkheim Weber I
actually threw mank in him because he's
really a sociological observer reiative
Adlon and now it starts to become just
sort of a mix of stuff that has to do
with history or you know ideas over time
and it's kind of a mishmash and then you
know there's towards the end I just
started throwing things on the shelf
that I hadn't found other places for and
and some of that's great stuff I mean I
like Fukuyama and robert nichols
political parties is there there's even
a book called the protestant crusade
which is quite interesting about what
took place in the Americas in the 1800s
[Music]
on one of the upper shelves they have
cobblestones history of philosophy the
volumes I was trying to find those
whenever I can and then a lot of what we
can call MIDI V alia you know stuff that
has to do with the medieval period in
one way or another that didn't fit very
well into everything else that we
already had on the Shelf you see blue
box medieval exegesis they're wonderful
stuff the feel of kaalia and a number of
other volumes and then we finish up with
some stuff that has to do with Judaism
and Judaic thought
I did manage to devote one shelf
primarily to Alistair McIntyre you see
some Palani in there as well in a copy
of the Lord of the Rings but you see a
lot of McIntyre stuff including two
copies of after virtue different
editions you know the entire thing and
then some works on McIntyre as well here
on this shelf in addition to an old
family Bible you see the collected works
of the anta and post Nicene Church
Fathers lots of really cool stuff in
there I bought that that entire lot a
long long time ago and I've transported
it with me all over my travels and and I
do draw on it quite a bit so I've got a
good bit of fiction and literature on my
bookshelf as well not in any particular
order so you see Shakespeare locked in
you know next to Arthur Conan Doyle next
to have even Lanois I didn't try to put
these in order at this point in time
because I just you know didn't see the
the need for it but you can see some of
the stuff that I've held on to because
I've actually gotten rid of most of my
literature stuff in the last move now
this I think you'll find interesting
there's an entire shelf devoted to
dictionaries and lexicons and grammars
and stuff like that from the various
languages that I've either learned or
tried to learn at one point in time and
then as we go back up we see more
literature stuff collected works of
O'Henry complete works of Edgar Allen
Poe and then all of these anvil books I
needed a place to put them and that was
the shelf you think you can tell a
common theme as we get closer and closer
to the end there's less and less good
organization and I'm not gonna try to do
the Ken Burns effect and lead you
through stuff here you can see lots and
lots of fiction books piled up here a
lot of stuff that I'll be reading I
haven't gotten rid of any of it yet I
hold on to it there's also quite a bit
of the you know religious studies
materials here
and and some you know philosophy of
language philosophy of religion and you
can even see that I've held on to some
journals and some textbooks that that
I've accumulated in my time but quite
frankly I have gotten rid of way more
books than I have held on to over the
course of the last probably two years
all right so there you have it that is
the tour of our bookshelves at present
after I put them into more or less order
orderly in some places are still a
little bit disorganized in some other
places a little bit of work yet to do
but you can tell where my priorities
really lie by what it is that I've held
on to you know we came here to to
Milwaukee with about 90 bankers boxes
full of books and we had to trim those
down mercilessly forcing you know for me
as a scholar as somebody who does
research somebody would love to hold
onto books a bibliophile a kind of
crisis where I had to think about am I
actually going to ever read this book
again or am I just keeping it on the
shelf and and in some way holding myself
back so I'm pretty happy with the
bookshelf as we have it and I and I
found it even though I spent an entire
day going through them and sorting them
and placing them where where they were I
found it it kind of a liberating
exercise to do so I hope you enjoyed the
little tour and you can leave your
comments below don't send me any books
unless you know you want me to review
them because I've already got quite a
few
and we actually try to avoid going to
use bookstores and the like because we
don't want to add too many new books to
the shelves but that's it so there's
there's the whole book
[Music]